well jeff zucker's cnn departure adds
another embarrassing headline to the
network's long list of controversies but
his exit is raising new questions about
the network and their reliable sources
here to break it down fox news
contributor joe koncha joe you have a
foxnews.com op-ed on this very topic and
you say there is much more to this story
so the question is what is it
well for starters obviously the carly
the turmoil the anger uh the back and
front stabbing at cnn right now it's
like king's landing all right forget
game of thrones it's game of microphones
over there okay the network is
winterfell 2.0
i mean look you had a meeting yesterday
internal anchor jake tapper uh called
chris cuomo a hostage who is uh i'm
sorry a terrorist who was holding the
network hostage uh called in the bad guy
as if jeff zucker here is is the good
guy and and reports now are saying that
jeff zucker and his girlfriend who was
one of the top executives there allison
gullist
coached then governor andrew cuomo on
interviews on on how to best attack then
president trump at the time on his
handling of covid
yet cnn is lionizing jeff sucker uh this
this activist president as if he's the
most ethical most successful network
president in history and let's talk
about the successful part by the way cnn
has lost 90 percent of its audience from
the same date in 2021 think about that
10 people who were watching cnn one year
ago nine of them have left the room now
uh reports also say uh that we
are seeing that this relationship
between zucker and gallus hasn't been
going on since covid
like cnn has been reporting
it's been going on since fox news was
born in 1996 25 years so this
relationship between zucker and gullist
not even an open secret it was open and
it's just so fitting that even in its
reporting of the resignation of its
network's president you have cnn's media
guy omitting or misrepresenting multiple
key details of the story that he
absolutely has intimate details of
warner media heads and new
shake holders here uh stakeholders
excuse me are certainly taking note of
this no question well well that's a
great point joe in fact we can show you
an insider talking to daily mail called
out
cnn's media guy brian stelter saying the
network needs to step up and fire brian
stelter he is allegedly our top media
reporter yet he failed to report on the
scoop that everyone in the office knew
and if he wants to say he didn't know he
is truly terrible at his job harsh words
joe does brian survive this
that's an excellent question because you
know
we're supposed to believe
that a network president of about 10
years has to abruptly resign because of
a consensual relationship with another
single executive not one person on the
planet believes this yet this is what
cnn's media correspondent is trying to
push
the bottom line is that chris cuomo
apparently has the goods the receipts on
his former boss uh and he wants to get
paid out on his contract at this point
and to think that nobody knew about this
relationship or cnn's media
correspondent uh is suddenly shocked and
surprised by all this he was very close
to the network president probably still
is probably still texting him multiple
times a day on how to handle this
so what happens from here that's up to
the new stakeholders from discovery when
they take over they're gonna look at
this culture here at cnn and say okay
who needs to stay and who needs to go
where we could get this stench off of us
at this point so uh it's up to them i'm
not gonna uh wager a guess on that yeah
well your game of thrones analogy was
very fitting
i never want to be a part of any type of
situation that is is
is related to that joe thank you so much
for joining us thanks for joining me oh
no problem when when pyro's around you
got to watch your back but but but
you're safe with grip he's one of the
good guys he's jon snow of the fox news
thank you joe thank you have a great
weekend my friend hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now